how was your day going excellent stars
actually quite good so much more
enjoyable process I can't imagine
mething you really did I was wondering
who character was so high up in the
hierarchy and you would think he's was
Escobar and he could not sense the ret
in Bachmann sir how is that possible
because he found in Bodmin sewer a
reflection of himself a man like Roberto
I you know as as playful film is nothing
if not careful discreet you use himself
as a protective principle even in the
business of you
makes his money in
as a legal and his dangerous it is what
he expects of themselves we expected
anyone around it is someone who's
trustworthy loyal sony was discreet
someone who follows orders and bob
presents himself in the fall of this
very wealthy crooked money launderer as
the kind of person that is very similar
to volcano
by design and so he didn't smell her at
because he thought he was amongst his
own kind you know one of the things that
beyond the value of a book and actual
conversations with bombs or that I
thought most vile too valuable to me as
an actor was I had access to the actual
tapes they're surreptitious recordings
between bombs or an uber volcano and in
hindsight teeth for me to project my own
thought about the underlying tension
that existed in the room or what have
you but what's very clear is that ninety
90 idea in part because the real Baba's
or pulled off the ultimate acting job
you discover just how deep undercover he
had to go and how how long term the plan
was to put it in place actually pull
this off from having numbers on the
stock exchange to having shell companies
whether it's
airline companies or bank accounts the
the fabric he built he weed was so
complex has to be entirely believable
and so it's easy to see why Roberto was
was so easily duped listening to those
tapes him preparing for the role do you
see Bob as an actor I i we I would say
that he likely didn't see himself as an
actor but I think in hindsight he was a
better actor than all look we make a
mistake on a set we got another take can
I go again in that case if he fails he
dies and it's actually it was actually
tear it's terrifying to listen to the
tapes because you realize almost in
every other interaction what i hear is
is the implied threat not directly to
bob's or not if you double-cross me i'm
going to kill you but how can you always
talk to generalities you know the people
i work with myself that we get double
crossed or someone takes from me they're
going to be consequences it's there its
underlying it's not specific but with
that kind of
you know that kind of Menace hanging in
the balance I'm surprised he got through
you know two days let alone four years
of it
there's a point in the movie very your
character it's really justifying what he
does he's like well people wanted I'm
just giving the people what they want do
you think that he actually thought that
or was it just a front to you know I the
way I played it in the film I believe
that's his real perspective it's twisted
logic of course but you know you're
talking about someone who's a chilean
national he's a south america and
america is the land of opportunity for
anyone not born in this country i think
that's the general perception and not
necessarily inaccurate but he twists
that that logic and uses it to a thing
sleep at night I don't think he ponders
it launched by this point the game but
what we discovered is that if he does he
clearly doesn't see himself as a villain
and it would have been a mistake from
from me as an actor to pre determine
whether he's a good guy or a bad guy
that's not my job my job was to make him
seem real and so what's provided on the
page is what we've discovered as an
opportunity to play someone who's not
unlike Bob's or they're almost mirror
images of children hero that both men of
integrity and principal with a both
loyal friends both family men Roberto
arcane knows a man of faith as we come
and a father he's charming sophisticated
his Worley just a lot about him it's
admirable he's an international drug
trafficking too but again he's got this
rear perspective where I'm doing
something good there's a vacuum here
there's a need for drugs and I'm solute
mass over to provide them how kills was
it please go on and I was wondering some
of his psyche must be entangled with
Escobar's have threat to everybody was
it worth it was close to him he was very
closely watching but they were doing and
actually his life was always under
lioness as much as my source well it is
part of public record that okay you know
had direct interface with members of the
of the board of the Medellin Cartel
including Pablo so he was considered one
of the top lieutenants he was also on
some level an independent contractor
devised opportunities for his own
shipments I think the one thing that
everyone understood is that it's not
unlike in the days of Caesar where we're
men of power even within a shared
community identities if you will they're
always looking over their shoulder
because you have to be double crossings
happen cheats happen and so there's this
there's this hyper sense of impending
doom and you have to sort of you have to
always be mindful of that and I think
that's why I know real Tate's what I
picked up on was there was this always
this mentioning of this generality of
know what happens to us because bad
things happen to people Dibble crosses
how do you know when a role is right for
you do you feel it like when you read
the script how do you know when you
really feel like you could put yourself
in a place in this character I I for me
I had to I have to hear a voice and I
don't game yes you should do if I can
hear the voice of the character and I'm
not just talking about cadence or
resonance or rapidity of speech if I can
relate to strongly to any aspect of who
this person is and what they're about
then then then I feel like I might have
chance of being successful at it in this
case the role itself in general terms is
not unfamiliar territory back to me I
have played members of of cartels before
leaders of cartels and other films and
it's something I typically would
sidestep have done it already but in
this case it was the first opportunity I
had as a performer to play someone in
this realm who actually seems like a
real human being and it's in possession
as we've already talked about equalities
that I aspire to having myself integrity
principle loyalty to family and friends
so those were the things that I could
sort of glom onto and enliven in my
performance and that's really what I
took as my number one job is to make
this person human and likeable how did
you get a little project most people
don't know that brad furman and I go way
way back I met Brad when he was a 19
year old kid in New York City I was
working on television series called long
order and my agent ICM had an assistant
it was Brad Furman and he would run
scripts down to me at Chelsea Piers
where we shot the show you know all
we've always full of enthusiasm you know
not a little naivete and it's so
remarkable to me now some 20 years later
to see him have developed into this
thoughtful very skilled very intelligent
director he's got so much potential I
can't wait to see what he does next and
you know he not unlike some of the
characters in the film he's an extremely
loyal guy as are a lot of us within his
personal circle as
you might recognize his work with John
Leguizamo before he's worked with Yul
Vasquez before who plays he's worked
with bryan cranston before in the
lincoln lawyer so
you know it coming full circle if you
will to this point he's been a sheer joy
we had a great time shooting in London
it feels a bit like this is dajon Bryan
Cranston and we're all just living in it
it's like everything he does is
personally I don't get it good let me
have you met the guy is a negative God
what's what's so remarkable about Brian
and there are a number of things that
are remarkable about him is that here's
a guy who has been in the trenches for
years and years for decades quietly
doing wonderful work and to see him
enjoy a level of success that he's
enjoying now and being rewarded with
both the hardware in terms of trophies
and the new wonderful roles of these so
capably rendering it's it's it's so
wonderful to see that and also see that
he remains hui always was which was a
very kind and humble man it was very
easy to be friend Brian as you all might
imagine when actors are shooting out on
distant locations and away from the West
similar to them
families and friends will tend to
congregate together and we spent a lot
of social time together and Brian and I
became fast friends and my hope is that
I think the result is there to be seen
is that our real off-screen friendship
played out on some level what do you
work on a character like do you do work
well maybe out in nature driving I mean
to you do you develop it do you kind of
get into it out of your own comfort zone
condition it changes as you get closer
to pulling the trigger and actually
jumping into it but yet personally I
tend to it becomes an ever-present
becomes an ever-present
idea or thought on my mind especially we
can do research you even start dreaming
about things it's like hearing a song
over and over and you can't get a song
my my why do I have Justin Timberlake if
you hear things that nausea men in a
similar way when you're reading books or
listening to tapes or doing research on
the net about cartels and that world
become so familiar to you that it prints
on the brain and whether you're driving
in a car or waking up in the middle of
the night or eating breakfast to drink
coffee it's always there at least for me
it is and you know again it's that
isolation on distant locations that
actually aids you might feel lonely but
you become almost single-minded in terms
of thing
only about the work even your off-camera
hours that's how I approach
you don't distract yourself at all
watching movies or anything are you will
be singing minded in the character yes I
think you know what i find as i my my 1
non-work-related indulgence beyond
eating a good restaurants is is reading
I'd love to read and I don't often have
a chance to even the newspaper The New
York Times my favorite when I'm at home
with two active kids and tons of other
responsibilities that go beyond far
beyond work I seldom have time to
actually sit down and read a novel so
for example while we were in London
caught up in a lot of reading and
normally I like fiction but I've found
myself with late being gone to
nonfiction I'm an information yes
I've money ah did you read the dark
money or minus just mentioning oh sorry
you have to leave it well sign it I was
in London so I read speeding
Greenblatt's of fire of Shakespeare will
in the world
we wrote an amazing
non-fiction book called this work
which is export the impact of the nature
of things a prose poem that was written
bye
an ancient Greek may well have been
responsible for creating the modern
world so yeah it's just an opportunity
to do things I don't way it's lonely but
it's productive how is it to watch
yourself I don't often enjoy it you
don't need to be honest but that said
when I feel like I've succeeded it's at
least bearable so I SAT through this
film and
I feel I felt exhausted by the end of it
by the by this expensive my detention I
know what happens and I didn't wince
that and he'll work that I was involved
in which i took he's a good sign but
ultimately I was really I felt a surge
of a pride and how well I thought Brad
did as a director he's wonderful wood
actors he's very smart about who he
assembles to perform his poems everyone
kills from Bryant and Ryan to Diane
Kruger
you'll pass cash to John and a whole
host of British actors who come in and
play American gangsters that actually
plays Dominic forgetting his name but he
was brilliant was that something you
really had to work on to watch I know so
many actors whether it's hearing
themselves on tape or third they're just
so critical of themselves even though
the world doesn't see them that way is
that something you had to almost feel
like that's part of the draw being an
actor is you could step outside of your
own perception of yourself and live out
loud via the personality in nature of
someone else I find that emancipated to
be sure and if I see aspects of myself
when a performance I don't enjoy it so
there are only a handful if that maybe
three performances that I've done that
where I can watch without wincing in
yellow is one of them the film I made in
two thousand where I met one of my wife
talisa soto not miss Yun is another one
that my brother broke directed
the jury's still having this yeah I do
you have aspirations to be like zero
aspirations to direct I just wanted a
few I wouldn't I wouldn't be comfortable
with that kind of responsibility I think
I have a knack for understanding how to
find solutions within a scene there's
something that's not going well whether
it's a piece of physical choreography
within a scene or narratively something
that's not quite jelanie um I don't
believe I have the temperament to be a
director and I certainly recognize that
I don't have the narrative scope to take
a story from
it's a huge responsibility in any given
moment you're you must answer to no less
than other people sometimes 300 people
depending on the size of the job and
making a movie is not easy especially on
the days when you're filming you're
always racing the clock you never have
enough time we didn't have enough time
on this phone given its scope grandeur
and I would not survive that kind of
pressure I'm what you call a red light
ball player so the camera rolls I
actually enjoy that kind of engagement I
feel the pressure to do what I have to
do and that gives me a kind of high
adrenaline rush for me but to take that
further and have to live with the
pressure of consideration of money and
time ticking clock and the producers on
me and the studio on me and actors you
know individual demands and what color
should the curtain be in look how short
should the show that hem on the jeans VI
I would lose my mind you're so invested
in a rolling you're reading up on the
GAR tells stories and info and watching
a better stuff is it easy to let go
again once you're done with the project
it's a good question it really depends
on the role what what what's what's more
difficult to let go is the the the
miniature and temporary family you
create with crew members
your fellow actors when you're awful
it's all it's part of the fun you know
that gypsylifestyle it's almost a member
of the circus where hey we're in this
this exciting never together oftentimes
struggle we all know that struggle
brings people together unites them so
all those elements are really wonderful
and they're binding and it makes for
great friendships it's always a little
bit sad for me to to leave even though
of course I'm going back to what I
treasure most of my wife and kids
thank you